في كلام كثير حول العالم مؤخرا عن زياده
في الوفيات المفاجئه وناقشنا الموضوع في
حلقه من كم يوم خاصه وانه في عالمنا
العربي الموضوع كثر الحديث عنه بعد وفاه
عدد من المشاهير مؤخرا وبشكل فجائي اخرهم
الفنان السعودي فهد الحيان قبله كان في
الفنان المصري مصطفى درويش قبله الفنانين
السوريين محمد قنوع وشادي زيدان وغيرهم
الموضوع ناقشنا مع استشاري امراض قلب
وشرايين من كم يوم واتكلم معانا انه فعلا
البيانات حول العالم بتظهر انه في زياده
فعلا في الوفيات بين الشباب واعطانا كمان
اسباب لهذا الشيء بعد ما نزلنا الفقره
لاحظنا انه كثير من تعليقاتكم مشاهدين
تساءلت عن جانب معين وهو كورونا ولقاح
كورونا كثير كان في تساؤلات عن العلاقه
بينهم وبين الزياده في الاوفيات المفاجئه
في العالم فرجعنا كلمنا دكتور اسلام
وطلبنا منه انه يرد علينا وهذا كان جوابه
في الواقع نحن تعلمنا في حقبه كورونا
ان مرض كوفي 19
قد يكون متسبب بارتفاع معاملات التجلط في
الجسم وقد يؤدي الى
اصابه بنوبات قلبيه اكثر لدى المصابين
بمرض كورونا او قد يتسبب نفسه باصابه
بجلطات قلب الجلطات رئويه او جلطات في
اماكن اخرى من الجسم
الحديث عن موضوع المطاعيم نفسها انها قد
تكون مؤثر سلبي او قد تتسبب لاحقا في
حالات من الجلطات او توقف القلب او
النوبات القلبيه المفاجئه حديث طويل وشائك
علميا اود ان انبه ان الحالات المرتبطه
بالمطاعيم هي حالات
اناس لديهم الاستعداد
لحدوث مثل هذا النوع من التجلط سواء قلبيا
او رئويا او تجلط في اماكن اخرى من الجسم
وهو مشابه لحاله قد تسبب فيها حتى بعض
[موسيقى]
المميعات في الدم مثل ماده الهيبرين وهم
معروف انه هو مسيل للدم وعلى العكس ما
يحصل عند بعض الناس هبوط في الصفائح
الدمويه مما تساعد على خلق حاله مناعيه
تؤدي الى احداث حاله من التجلط
نفس هذا النوع قد يكون قد يكون مصاحب
للتجلطات المصاحبه لبعض المطاعيم كورونا
لكن بالعاده لا تتسبب
التوقف
المفاجئ للقلب
المشاهدات اغلبها حالات تخثر سواء تجلطات
ورديه او جلطات رئويه ونادر جدا ما تكون
اصابات
بنوبات قلبيه
واعتقادي العلمي بناء على كثير من
الدراسات ان هؤلاء الذين اصيبوا بمثل هذه
الاصابه كان لديهم استعداد
جسدي اكثر من غيرهم بعوامل معينه وان
وراثيه او جينيه لديهم الاستعداد لحدوث
مثل هذه النوبات ولم يثبت ان هذه المطاعيم
هي بشكل واضح او مباشر المتسبب بحدوث
نوبات قلبيه او توقف مفاجئ للقلب او حدوث
وفاء مبكره او متسببه بالوفاه المفاجئه
[موسيقى]